a frightening image of the future as we
see garbage stacks as high as the
tallest buildings creating their own
skyline mainly due to its visual
humorous exciting storytelling this
movie kicks cinemasins asked so much in
the first half we're gonna remove three
sins right off the bat it's the anti
cinema sin movie really since so much of
it is anti what other movies do see even
the same counter doesn't obey in the
future you can train cockroaches to be
like dogs I can't wait to see the Sarah
McLachlan commercials for these poor
bastards how did the society so
dependent on fossil fuel ultimately
decide to put solar panels on something
as small as a PA system or did the
walley's do that because they liked the
song so much I'm sitting in either way
so take your pick
filmmaker said hey let's take Johnny 5
from short circuit and put him in a
bleak future with no humans where he's
stuck stacking up trash and now I'm
depressed as all hell robot main
character rides by multiple dead copies
of himself leading me to wonder why this
one wall-e was left alive after all the
others failed
was it his compassion for roaches you
see damn it stuff like this that's so
fun about this movie if this were a
DreamWorks movie this now wisecracking
robot would say it was conquer a trend
yes looks like I need some new treads
this guy won't be needing his anymore if
we play our cards right we'll be back in
time to watch The Sopranos but I being
gotta say the use of actual humans in
this cartoon footage is a little
unsettling it's not like we see actual
humans later when wall-e goes into space
so what's up with this I mean we hereby
interrupt this largely dialogue free
movie opening to bring you a ton of
dialogue heavy exposition Wow look at
all these human non robot trinkets this
asshole is stored up this worker robot
seems to have just enough personality to
qualify as AI basically he has a
favorite movie obsesses about
cleanliness collects trinkets and
crushes on a girl robot they should have
called this movie AI and saved about
three letters in a - wall-e plugs in a
video cassette into some sort of ancient
VCR which not only still works but is
compatible with an iPod also this old
VHS tape somehow plays with HD quality
and absolutely no static I'm also
compelled to ask how a robot so beholden
to his programming that he's still
compacting trash long after the other
wall-e units have broken down is still
so free-thinking to have collections and
favorite movie scenes and cockroach
friends is this AI or is it a slave bomb
you can't have it both ways damn it man
this sand storm warning seems awfully
late coming five seconds before the
storm hits and all the Twinkies and
cockroaches
the Apocalypse cliches finally get
married and have a baby why doesn't he
do this just before sundown at least a
little bit so his morning routine isn't
so full of I might actually die moments
when wall-e runs over its pet cockroach
we can clearly hear crunching and
cracking yet it gets back up with no
problem sorry kids this cute roach is
dead thankfully this plant doesn't have
deep roots or else Wally would have just
crushed humanity's chance at a new home
also luckily Wally finds proof that the
earth can still grow plants just minutes
before Eve shows up a robot built to
detect and report such things we find
out later that this red light is from a
spaceship that has many red lights so
how did this one escape and have a mind
of its own Scout robot whose deployment
has been almost all electrical until
this point somehow still requires a
completely separate machine to enter
some kind of passcode to be activated I
guess it's a wall-e you can experience
the dramatic reveal of his love interest
[Music]
how does he even know she's a girl robot
is this movie pushing a much stronger
sexual equality message than I realized
I mean gay or straight basically he
falls for her based on looks on pure
design why not hearing her say one word
so wall-e is kind of a sexist dick if
you think about it Eve's some sort of
plasma ray that causes a mushroom cloud
and wall-e survives it I get the joke
cockroaches are unkillable but where are
the millions of other cockroaches if
that's the case also I understand why
Eve would have weapons for self-defense
but why the shoot first ask questions
later mentality this electromagnet still
works man I see no solar panels wait all
these down here why is this magnet crane
even moving I'm serious this might be
the biggest mystery of the entire
goddamn movie and if you tell me it's
moving to follow her then how's the
magnets strong enough to detect and
follow her from this distance but not
pick her up until she gets even further
away classified so the humans made the
plant seeking robots mission classified
in case it encountered another robot
aliens I mean this movie doesn't show us
any aliens so who did they think might
even conceivably intercept this robots
objective malicious ah roll credits
opening this wall-e shed during a
massive sandstorm for even this short
span of time would definitely fill this
thing with 70% sand and debris robot
sneeze this is funny but we all know how
Eve operates and the singing bass and
half of Wally's living space would
surely be obliterated before Wally could
stop her just tell her that toasters
bread holes Jesus there's no way on
earth future were present that she hit
him hard enough too intense steel like
this without also destroying him in the
process but whatever good visual gag Al
position was it basically the Benny and
June of robot movies Eve's up till now
autonomous nature is completely
overtaken by native programming when she
sees a sign of life why would she ever
autonomous in the first place
while he gets struck by lightning twice
in rapid succession because this movie
is either trying too hard to show how
selfless he is or is making a weird Jim
Caviezel parallel I was unprepared for
Oh what kind of society was the future
living in where wall-e could easily find
an Atari 2600 and a playable cartridge
of pong Holly finally goes off to work
and stops waiting for Eve to come back
online how much you want to bet this is
the exact same day the space humans come
for Eve god damn it wall-e waste a bunch
of precious Eve saving time driving back
to show the cockroach where to stay this
cockroach is like dude you forgot to
open the shut door so I can get to the
Twinkie bed why didn't you give me a
cockroach friendly garage door opener
for this exact situation Molly is a dick
to alien robots because these robots are
so awful at their jobs while he is
allowed to escape from the situation
plus the little cleaning robot that he
totally
angered a minute ago and decided not to
narc on they have no way of having their
Eve probes send word of their findings
ahead of the actual robot arriving back
on the ship this cleaning robot must
completely immerse itself in 420
activities because it completely forgot
about wall-e after 10 seconds also this
role Matt decides not to stir from the
beginning of the tread marks and leaves
an entire section of floor unclean Wow
so look I agree that if a bunch of
people from Earth especially Americans
were shot into space and they were on
permanent hold until earth was habitable
again most of them would turn these
bunch of fat lazy assholes but all of
them you know there would be at least
10% of the group annoyingly thin jogging
around the ship eating vegan and
tracking kale everywhere in fact how
does this a lot of fat bastards even
breed there's apparently enough sexual
activity going on for this to be going
on for generations but none of these
people even know how to move much less
sex each other time for lunch
in a cop this is Pixar's most biting
satire to date before this movie all the
messaging in Pixar films have been self
esteem related and feel-good Forge story
is be a kid again
cars will slow down and enjoy life bugs
life was if you're a misfit be a proud
one and you can contribute but this
movie is on like yo America you were fat
and lazy and you know what I think
they're dead on with this exaggerated
future bring everything to me and put
everything in a cup so I can sip it and
I'm even gonna take once in on for Pixar
being right in its ballsiest film
messaging to date highly automated and
presumably efficient future society
places super important life proof
evidence robot on the same tram as
ordinary fat humans on their way to
chair based smoothie yoga are they
saying this is how long they ran the
ship cuz I don't care how good health
advances got over the years there's no
way these people survived that long
unless they're constantly provided
artificial hearts that can take the
abuse home we're going back if the evil
ship's computer steering thing behind
this guy is truly evil and trying to
stop the return to Earth as the rest of
the movie will suggest why does it even
allow the captain to press the button
and see this message in the first place
with a jogging truck considering that in
a second you don't even know how to
pronounce manual do you even know what
jogging is operate man well haha but
Fred Willard literally said manual twice
during that presentation including one
second before you looked at the manual
one voice command confirm acquisition
confirm acquisition okay so how are you
reading this when you couldn't even
pronounce operation manual just before
this hilarious but damn future voice
activation software is far outpaced
plant life detection software or tiny
robot intruder detection software or
don't get fat and lazy software
no bro robots why would the robot
security team bother to inform all the
people about rogue robots when they can
simply arrest them right now instead of
closing the pod door making sure he
stays on the pod EEP turns around and
glides toward some unseen control panel
to ensure while he escapes again here
comes Wally riding his fire extinguisher
but damn he had one second left before
the pod destructed and he still didn't
get the door open at that time don't you
think he's dead what would happen to an
earth plant exposed to space dr. Tyson
oh snap we got him for interstellar not
this well I'm sending it then if humans
choke and freeze to death in seconds I'm
guessing regular plants suffer some
serious consequences that this movie is
completely glossing over and here comes
the point in the movie where I eat if I
don't take a sin on for help damp great
this movie is way to waste your
propulsion substance ass accidental meat
fat also because our hands touched
accidentally we must be in love cliche
fine oh this guy's been researching
earth a few minutes and somehow ended up
at hoedown I realize this comment is
intended to show the extreme clueless
laziness of humans but you're telling me
this 100% marketed BNL cruise ship isn't
shoving all the craps amenities like
pools down the residents throats via
constant advertisements security cam
footage will now conveniently tell Eve
what she should already know that Wally
loves her and sacrifices himself for her
thank God for the kind of romantic
comedy love proof real-life humans never
actually get this asshole is such a
slave to his cleaning program it makes
me wonder how Wally he ever fell in love
with Eve instead of just ignoring her to
do his program tasks discount homage Hal
9000 also this a113 directive is such
that it makes you wonder why the
computer-controlled ship even bothered
to continue dropping off Eve's on earth
if the directive could never be broken
so this proves the captain can order
auto to do his bidding
yeah auto will still represent a
significant threat throughout the rest
of this movie because of those reasons
movie steals 90% of its dialogue
template from Titanic wall-e rips off
the zero-point energy from the
Incredibles
that one makes classic stupid-ass
mistake of sending his nemesis and said
nemesis helper to the same place you can
bet that anytime a robot is shut down or
broken a reboot or an alternative power
source will revive them
not only did the wall-e robots man's to
snack Eve and wall-e next to each other
but both robots happen to be crunched
into these garbage cubes at just the
right spot in order to still communicate
low BOTS the dormers ex machina I can't
the guard robot used the same death-grip
ray on Eve that it's using on this other
robot the captain smartly retrieves the
image of wall-e and the plant so he can
trick the evil robot into thinking he
has it problem is the captain didn't see
this part of the transmission because
Eve was alone when that image came up so
he shouldn't even know this exist having
a good look at all these people that
comprise the axiom reminds me that this
ship appears entirely American even if
that's not true I wonder how this ship
handles politics I have so many
questions about this arrangement now
that we'll be stealing the ending of
Titanic movie makes an attempt to make
these human characters matter but these
kids are in virtually no danger they
simply would have landed in the ungodly
mass of humanity further down unharmed
you may have forgotten by this point due
to all the adventure in action that has
occurred since we last really saw him
Holly can barely move because a
motherboard inside him is damaged but I
guess the power of robe owners can give
you strength in certain situations movie
will now and reinforce the lie that just
because you really want to win you can
do that despite all obstacles including
the fact that you haven't used your
muscles since you were born
ten seconds to hyper jump the ship
decides that can go into hyper jump ten
seconds after a plant gets inserted into
a thing doesn't it need to worry about
safety and these assholes are mildly
inconvenience when the ship blasts into
hyperspace and they're not even buckled
in or anything the Walia amnesia is of
course heartbreaking but it's no
different from the movie that makes you
think the main character dying for two
minutes before his or her hand
dramatically appears on the edge of the
cliff
of course wall-e is going to remember
this is Disney not Paul Schrader tiny
electrical spark will somehow return
Wally's memory loss because that's how
electronics work baby instantly kills
the only plant Earth has with whatever
the hell is in that Cup when wall-e he
appears for a mini end credits sequence
he changes the Pixar lamps light bulb
replacing it with a CFL bulb to be more
environmentally friendly but when Pixar
returns next year with Toy Story 3 that
asshole has his old environmentally
wasteful ball back in
because I choose not to ride
[Music]
silly customer you cannot let the
Twinkie you bro pawn better work
nerdling err
[Music]
the Sun is energizing powers are
replenishing my strength
closer closer oh god yes can you read my
mind for the last time I'm pretty sure
what's killing the crops is this bran
dose
you
[Music]
keep trying to pick a fight but I'm
still just happy you're alive the future
is a butt that farts horror this is the
story of a cat who lives with a young
woman in a trailer park
not too many years from now the young
woman is named Zoe Ashe and her cat
smells like a dumpster behind a seafood
restaurant on a hot summer day one day a
little hologram man tells Zoe that some
bad men are coming to kill her
these men can do magic using technology
because it is the future and such things
are possible Zoe and her smelly cat must
travel to a strange land called Utah in
which many people are dying in exotic
and gruesome ways now I don't want to
spoil too much of the story so let's
just say that things only get weirder
from there will Zoe find a way to save
mankind from itself and will she do it
in time to be back at work for her
Monday morning shift at the cafe or
we'll both Zoe and her cat be horribly
murdered by cyborgs you will have to buy
this book to find out futuristic
violence and bitsy suits a novel by New
York Times bestselling author David Wong
you can find it wherever books like this
are sold or just go to futuristic
violence calm and order it that way it's
even available as an audiobook if you
think reading is stupid the book has
been called subtly brilliant by
Publishers Weekly and booklets calls it
explosive smart and witty futuristic
violence and fancy suits is an adventure
suitable for all ages
except for
who will be traumatized
[Music]